hey 42 here you would think that with
the rapid industrialization of our world
in the past 100 years there would be
nowhere left to hide
well the Stone Age civilization of the
Sentinelese people have managed to say
booger after cheeseburgers and
smartphones and permanently isolate
themselves from the rest of the world
the Sentinelese haven't had a single
pork scratching of contact with other
humans and the few bumpkins they have
had have all ended up with the intruders
becoming pork scratchings there are
estimated to be around 100 so-called
uncontacted tribes left in the world
people who have had little to no outside
contact one such tribe lives on the
remote North Sentinel island in the Bay
of Bengal between India and Malaysia
there are estimated to be anywhere
between 50 to 500 members of the tribe
I'm not incredibly very number it's just
a sentiment to how little we've been
able to find out about them but what we
do know about these genital waggling
tribes people after observing them from
boats and helicopters is that they are
incomprehensibly primitive they use
Stone Age tools and live a
hunter-gatherer lifestyle and have no
understanding of Agriculture and
amazingly they haven't even discovered
how to make fire
they simply wait for lightning to strike
and then attempt to keep the embers
burning for as long as possible
seriously I imagine it's really annoying
when you plan to cook a Sunday roast but
you can't because there hasn't been any
lightning that week it's thought that
the Sentinelese people are directly
descended from the very first human
populations to emerge from Africa and to
this day their methods of hunting and
living have remained vally unchanged for
over 60,000 years they have remained
uncontacted for now but not for our lack
of trying
there have been numerous documented
attempts to make contact of the tribe
and all of them have ended with Eva the
visitors being sued away with a hail of
arrows or they have been captured by the
tribes people and brutally murdered two
fishermen were illegally fishing in the
water
rounding North Sentinel island the men
got so drunk that they were unable to
sail back to the mainland
and instead fell asleep aboard their
boat which during the night drifted onto
the shore of North Sentinel island the
tribe ran out of the jungle and attacked
the two men with arrows and Spears
leaving them for dead
a few days later the Indian Coast Guard
sent a helicopter to recover the men's
bodies from the island which were
viewable from the air but as the
helicopter neared the island it was met
with a hail of arrows from the ground so
the helicopter ran away with its tail
between its legs
they don't even contact other local
tribes like most tribes do most tribes
in the area share a similar language but
the Sentinelese have their very own
unique language that no one else can
interpret but you can't really blame
them for their hostility towards
outsiders their only previous contact
with other humans ended up with two of
their fellow tribes people dying during
the British Empire those well-dressed
tea enthusiasts oh wait that's me
for that the entire world was theirs for
the taking and they were go to extreme
lengths to do so the British had a
system for entrapping isolated tribes
and taking their land first they were
kidnapped a few tribe members and take
them back to the British camp where they
would treat them like royalty and shower
them with gifts and then they would
return them to their people in the hope
that they would tell the rest of the
tribe and they would go okay these
British guys on to pass enabling the
British just sweep in and take their
land without hostility the plucky Brits
were pros at this and they succeeded
time and time again until they tried it
with the Sentinelese people the British
sailed to North Sentinel island which is
believed to be the first outside a
contact of the island and they kidnapped
two elderly tribes people and four young
children they took them back to the
nearby British settlements at Port Blair
and began their friendly indoctrination
of the captured tribes people a few days
later the two elderly members got sick
and died so the British fought with
not going to do too well at winning over
the trust of the rest of the Sentinelese
people after we just killed their granny
in Graham Hobbs so they let the children
go and simply left the island alone
it wasn't understood why the two elderly
tribe people died at the time but we now
know from encounters with other tribes
that the years of isolation has left
their immune system several thousand
years behind the developed world so
diseases which modern medicine has long
since conquered such as influenza and
smallpox can easily devastate an entire
uncontacted tribe after just a single
encounter with an outsider the Indian
government has since realized that the
Sentinelese are forever annoyed is our
incessant attempt to be their friends
and have recently passed a law which
banned all contact with the tribe
thinking that they are best left alone a
jail sentence awaits anyone who attempts
to travel to the island now the last we
saw of the tribe was when the Indian
Ocean tsunami hit the area in 2004
killing more than 230,000 people in 24
countries the indian navy flew a
helicopter over North Sentinel island
just to make sure that they had survived
the deadly tsunami fearing the entire
tribe could have been killed
but as they neared the islands -
helicopter who's once again hit with
arrows indicating that the Sentinelese
people were alive and well and
thankfully up to their same old violent
tricks thanks for watching think back to
the last time you had an apple when do
you think it was picked a couple of days
ago a couple of weeks ago perhaps try a
year ago wise a 1.2 square kilometer
island called Haun's Islands and Canada
in Denmark just can't help but put their
sticky hands all over